and in less than a week Black Friday
will kick off the holiday shopping
season and this year it may set records
analysts say holiday spending may top a
trillion dollars here in the US for the
first time ever and many retailers are
trying some innovative ways to attract
your business here to talk about it is
Vera Givens a finance expert and founder
and editor-in-chief of the website non
political news Vera a good morning I was
reading that 88 percent it's expected of
shopping is going to be done in stores
but we've been talking all of these
years about the death of
brick-and-mortar the rise of mobile
shopping they're going both places and
they're going to be spending big time I
mean the trillion dollars a lot of money
that is a lot of money and it's because
the economy is in good shape consumer
confidence is up on employments at a
50-year low gas prices are nice and less
if people are feeling pretty good
spending not only on others but
themselves a lot of self gifting going
on this holiday season I plan on buying
myself a new iPhone and I'm gonna sell
my other stuff I'm declutter calm to
actually make some money fast if I don't
feel so guilty about how I'm spending
money but stores are really doing a lot
there they're really breaking out all
the stuff they are rolling out all the
punches to capture some of these dollars
we're seeing more pop ups this year you
usually see them anyway but now you're
seeing even more of them it's a
relatively inexpensive way to draw a
traffic to try new things to offer that
experience to connect with consumers
face to face so like goup for example
has a couple of pop ups Facebook has
some pop ups Wayfair has a couple of pop
ups and the malls and then you're seeing
other stores sort of offer an extension
of what they sell via services so yeah
these stores these stores care Vera
whether you go online or you actually go
into the your money they just want your
money because about 20% of total sales
come from holiday shopping so they are
doing whatever they can to drive traffic
to get you in they just want to battle
it out and get a portion of that share
and it's going to be a very aggressive
competitive season with a big emphasis
on convenience simplicity keep it easy
for the consumers and keep them spending
speaking of consumers what are your tips
for consumers how can they get out of it
taken for my plan ahead and they use
certain apps and websites to actually
make sure they get the best discounts a
good thing this year is that shipping is
pretty much gonna be free I mean Amazon
set the precedent on that one when they
said a couple weeks ago
free shipping no minimum purchase you
know three member prime so all the other
retailers are sort of following suit and
offering free shipping as well which is
a nice bonus for consumers because the
one thing they hate shipping for
shipping one of the sales start veera
the sales have already started I mean
Black Friday creep started like last
week yeah so they're going on now and
right on through the holiday period the
good news for retailers is that they
have a couple extra days because
Thanksgivings a little early this year
so big money is expected Anthony did not
get the memo about you know Christmas
shopping starting right after already on
Anthony
well I always start for myself early but
it's the other people I weigh a little
longer men tend to procrastinate he's
just a little ass yes very good ass
thanks for being with us